of the three investigations into Trump
Russia we always sort of knew that the
house investigation was the least
credible it was after all at one point
being run by a guy who worked on the
Trump transition team Devin Nunez who
was also while he was running the
investigation running to the White House
to brief Donald Trump one of the
subjects of the investigation about what
they were up to next
was the Senate investigation in terms of
credibility and that was followed by the
the third of three investigations which
I believe is the most credible at this
time
special prosecutor Robert Muller's
investigation and the big news breaking
over the last 12 or 16 hours is that the
house intelligence committees Trump
Russia investigation is over or is it
and at least according to the
Republicans on the House Intelligence
panel has found no evidence of collusion
between Donald Trump and Russia
whatsoever wow what a big announcement
right how did they all agree that this
was it that it's over that there's
nothing more to do and that there's been
no collusion oh wait they didn't all
agree
Republicans unilaterally decided that
they were done and the investigation
will not be doing any more interviews
whatsoever but Democrats said now now
that this is totally premature were not
done not only are we not done we weren't
even even involved in the drafting of
this memo which says it's over and there
was never any collusion and Republicans
effectively have decided we've
investigated Republicans have invested
the Republican president and his
Republican aides and have determined
that they've done nothing wrong
effectively they've cleared the guy
running their own party from the Oval
Office
of any wrongdoing in case in point the
draft Republican memo actually says the
opposite of what our entire intelligence
community says and Republican
congressman Michael Conaway who's in
charge of the house investigation has
been in charge of it since Devin Nunez
had to recuse himself he says there was
no call
he says there might have been some bad
judgment there might have been some
inappropriate meetings there might have
been inappropriate judgment about which
meetings to take but that there was
nothing beyond that and again that memo
the draft memo done with no input from
any of the Republicans on this committee
who participated in this investigation
at any point understand this the
Republicans who previously led in this
investigation were involved with Trump's
transition and they've now decided
unilaterally without having to talk to
Democrats apparently that the Republican
President did nothing wrong what a major
revelation right and we heard already
from Democratic congressman Adam Schiff
who makes a really good point actually
in a statement he released which is that
the total lack of credibility of this
Republican decision is going to be made
even more obvious in the coming months
because Adam Schiff believes there are
going to be more indictments from robert
muller there is going to be more
investigative journalism that is going
to reveal even more connections here and
if Adam Schiff is right this very
strange and seemingly premature
declaration from the Republicans in the
house is going to seem particularly
strange and what this means to me is
that huge major news is about to drop
and that this is one of these
pre-emptive distraction attempts this
could be also an attempt to indirectly
discredit robert muller in the idea that
if and when robert muller has something
big you will have a contingent of the
Republican Party and Trump himself
already primed to say wait a second
molars running a witch hunt the
Republican the the House Intelligence
Committee has already cleared me of
wrongdoing which of course is not really
what has taken place here it's
Republicans unilaterally saying the
investigation is done and you can
already see Trump taking advantage of it
right Trump immediately taking to
Twitter and in all capital letters rant
where he says the House Intelligence
Committee has after a 14 month long
in-depth investigation found no evidence
of collusion or coordination between the
Trump campaign and Russia to influence
the 2016 presidential election don't be
confused okay there's no news here in
terms of the investigation itself other
than Republicans decided that after
obstructing the investigation for months
they're going to end it they didn't
interview Paul Manafort they didn't
interview Rick gates they didn't
interview Michael Flynn Michael Flynn
understandably might not be allowed as a
result of the deal that he has struck
with Robert Muller but how can any
investigation into Trump Russia end or
be complete without interviewing those
people and to be called finished at that
time it is a total and complete sham and
again every statement made by the
Republicans on that committee directly
contradicts the assessments of the
entire intelligence community and it is
complete and total part partisanship
that we are seeing how can you look at
that Trump Tower meeting for example
where there was a very clear quid pro
quo offered right dirt on Hillary from
the Russians in exchange for the easing
of sanctions by the then possible future
Trump administration how do you look at
the Carter page Moscow trip the attempt
by Jared Kushner to create a
back-channel with the Kremlin
specifically to circumvent American
intelligence agencies knowing about
those communications and then of course
the circumstantial appearance of
coordination between Russia and
WikiLeaks combined with the very
suspicious timing of public declarations
from Donald Trump related to the
material ultimately published by
WikiLeaks and that's only what we
publicly know about that's only what we
publicly know about how can you see all
that and say now there's nothing here
we're ending the investigation it
completely belies credulity and in fact
former Director of National Intelligence
James clapper has already said this memo
of this declaration from Republicans on
the House Intelligence
in their own reality bubbles where we
cannot even agree with basic facts
who's telling you the truth that is
really the question here right is it the
career intelligence officials who saw
all of the intelligence and have been
dealing with Russia for years a team of
respectable and experienced lawyers that
are working with robert muller or the
republican equivalent to devin Nunez you
decide who you find more credible but
there's an important element here when
it comes to the timing
I believe Robert Muller will have
something big to announce soon and as a
result of making this declaration the
Republicans will be able to come back
and say look molars crooked the House
already said no collusion and of course
molars looking into things in way more
detail than the House Committee molar is
looking into this not only at the
collusion itself but at possible
obstruction of the investigation itself
at financial crimes that may have taken
place in the lead-up to or in whatever
coordination or meddling Russia may have
been involved in and much more but to me
this is a sign that they are very
worried about something major happening
soon and bear in mind that there are
some trumpets who just don't even get
the headlines
I already saw online Trump is to believe
that because the Republicans in the
House said the investigation is over
that Robert Moeller is done which of
course isn't the case right we I think
most of our audience realizes that the
Robert Miller investigation is
completely separate from the house
investigation they just nebulously are
aware of uninvestigated they don't
necessarily know that there are three
different ones and to then this means
Trump is vindicated so if only in the
propaganda battle this declaration from
House Republicans is going to make it
even more difficult to explain to the
committed trumpets that Robert Moeller
appears to really only be getting
started this declaration from
Republicans that they are done in the
house investigating Trump Russia is
basically like another new Ness memo it
is a meaningless highly partisan
knee-jerk attempt to distract the video
you just finished watching was made
possible by you
the membership program you can sign up
for membership at david pakman.com slash
membership we are viewer supported
independent media you can use the coupon
code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership